hello world welcome to this video this
is coverage for all seven of the London
chess classic a little bit late that
video but I'm going to let that I
managed to do it in the first place
because I was i am really busy this
weekend and well normally speaking at I
shouldn't even done the video but okay
yeah I want to keep coverage complete
round seven was a very interesting round
and one reason why I'm so busy this
weekend it's that because i was also i
had something to do on friday that was
not planned at all I was the replacement
for Grand Master Larry Christians and
doing live commentary for the ICC again
so I was live for seven hours for that
round together with Grandmaster an exam
Olinsky filling in for Larry it was a
great experience we had lots of fun and
was very good learning experience for
think both the audience and also for me
in some cases with the Yama being an
excellent endgame expert so let's see
what we had in this round so it's not
the coverage that I would love to do
it's not as deep as some it could be but
it's what I can do so please be a yeah
be aware that I had a little time to do
this so we have a trump in this game
Caruana geary what the Trump yes this is
still an opening and why not I mean in
those son Berlin defenses Giri yes
probably yeah just repeating some kind
of prep for 25 moves and will draw so
why not the Trump but we see here with
Geary's time spent he played quickly
very interesting line like it gives up
the center here for the moment or let
that st. he gives up that porn and
allows why to take and it's not getting
the porn back just yet whitby form White
is trying to keep it quite an
interesting approach
but after six before a five we see that
black is immediately charged oh yeah I'm
fight against this bind on the queenside
and it's difficult for why to keep it if
you go Bishop b5 a move that I suggested
during the broadcast just Bishop d7 it's
probably okay for black black OS has
ideas to break this thing or break the
thing up with b6 for example like here
takes and b6 note that black has the
total bishop pair here this is quite two
bishops against two lights the blankets
definitely alrighty yet this was played
by caruana and now given def 5 now first
spending some time and he got this
Bishop on the long diagonal very nice b5
now Ibaka wanna this is a good practical
decision I think he will lose the porn
back and this will be the c5 poem but in
the process and at least black has to
lose some time by putting his night back
it went back to make sure that this pawn
is actually falling on c5 and in the
meantime why got some things coordinated
c6 here big stakes and again back to be
aged very funny what give you did he
with his night we expected in the
broadcast at 95 would be played but
after Queen a three green d6 there is a
move see form and here white is
definitely not worse intending to
capture note that white has just covered
this here I think white is probably
better this is my GV went back to be
eight and now we will get the point back
on c6 in the meantime however wide gets
some coordination going and especially
important is that he gets in c4 again
give me now just played on very yeah
very cool headed sensible approach 937
and here White has to be alert about the
bishop am if he is not
they are playing as actively as possible
with his better yeah mobilisation of
horses he will be worth against verse
against the bishop so he opens up the
position and tries to play with Tempe
like he is taking the night getting this
in trying to get rook be worn in so
white has the better activity but black
has the long-term ideas with the two
bishops in the game this proved to be
completely equal on technical terms like
here Rudy CH is a very good defense
changing to this kind of simplification
and black is just about in time and he's
covering the a5 pawn and has
counter-attacking ideas with Bishop g5
against the airport here we go and this
is how the game now ended they traded
the airport and here agreed to a draw
not a super exciting game but it had
some some some content and the main
reason why I am NOT looking at this
little bit more it was possible yes
besides the time constraint is that the
other games are far more interesting so
this is just a short coverage of that
that game okay let's go to the next one
yeah Adams grecian um those both the
players having a very solid tournament
we should be zone plus one having beaten
Ireland and draw draw straws and Adams
is mr. draw himself he has played draws
exclusively seven or six out of this is
Ron 77 let's run six out of six for
round seven ok I'm getting getting
confused so he played or drawers and
turn well if I'm doing this game now you
probably have the suspicion that this is
going to end in a draw as well and I'm
yeah I'm going to going to tell you
right away it will be it will be end in
a row okay so Adams went for a g3 line
against the night off and Grisha quent
form a dragon type of
mation why not all super solid there's
just one particular thing of interest
here 95 that was played by Adams the
ideas that the knight on d5 is it's
tough to tolerate for a very long time
and after a pawn gets to the fire this
is what happens shortly White has some
ideas to play on the half-open efile
maybe against that e 7 pole currently
the e-file is sort of plucked by them
Bishop on e3 and then not only five but
this is a long-term plan and black has
to be pretty circumspect not to allow
this kind of scenario to happen you
absolutely have to make sure that why
does not getting all this in and we
shook is doing a good job he activates
his annoyed and its Queen and it's
difficult now one thing that white would
love to do is to play b3 and ce4 but if
he goes be three he's blundering the
game this is what Adams tries to prepare
now with this rook a to move now o be
three is an is an option but Grisha
played in a very aggressive where you
went b5 that's interesting possibility
immediately using the fact that this
rook is unprotected so white cannot
capture on b5 first glance that move b5
looked a bit suspicious because of 96
yeah that night entering blacks position
but black can just take and go e 6
that's a very important resource like is
going for d5 and after d5 that c6 porn
is kind of isolated from the rest of
whites army and we'll get lost yeah not
for nothing but it is something that
might happen yeah here d5 was no good
because of the tactic yeah he takes
check check
and that's going to be made so no d five
pins but grigio goes of course not
falling into that Knight to e5 back and
he got that one back yeah b5 for
spawning c6 was falling we are talking
about an equal material position here
White has the two bishops but black has
definite play against those we can pause
it is something that delicately balances
each other out and they repeated here I
think they are both kind of content with
this result Adams making another draw in
a tournament where he's clearly the
underdog and gree shocked yeah
maintaining his plus one score with the
black pieces iam it's not a bad decision
at all he has to get a win in in the
later stages of that tournament because
he has this he has to try to get to the
third place in the overall standings of
the grand chance to her because that
would actually give him the entry card
for next year's cycle of the grand
chester but okay in that game was
probably that world would probably be
the wrong moment to try for something
fancy okay let's go to check the next
game all right this is Aronian to pawn
off that's the next game T'Pol off has
one of his worst tournaments I think
probably ever being on minus three I
would need to look it up it's pretty
terrible he lost a bunch of games and
didn't get to win a game and he had
chances like against Micky Adams aronia
on the other hand has made draw draw
draw draw draw draw draw so or drawers
and looking forward to try to win this
game probably and playing some role in
the overall standings he has won the
senior cup so if huronian would get in
like two wins in or so and then fine
couple of games he had decent very
decent chances to win that event and
with it the tour so C 4 and 2 pi love
goes with this quick d5 this is an
interesting line for black quite often
played by dynamic players who have the
Greenfeld in the repertoire why is that
because if why it takes and this is what
happened here if wide no goes d 4 which
is one of the main moves then black can
easily think about taking and with g6 it
could easily transpose to gruene felt
it's at least Greenfeld ish let's say
this is a pure green felt but why it
might also go here or something and stay
within the English opening but it has a
definite Greenfeld flavor aronian goes
efore however and this is an interesting
move and sister may be the sharpest move
available in the position the reason is
that after nine before Bishop c4 black
gets a check in this is the reason why
this is so sharp now white absolutely
does not want to capture him here this
makes a pretty awkward impression Black
has an excellent development and sorry
white has a good development but he
cannot Castle black has lost time but
without cancelling how do you play this
yeah this is a super annoying piece so
King you two ways to move check and back
yeah why this kind of route the night is
supposed to control the form and if
white has not yeah what does not get
define then it will be difficult really
difficult to coordinate the position how
is why going to do that there have been
a couple of tries in this position one
is 95 for example after which black
should absolutely avoid this no I have
seven and yeah black gets killed very
tricky line something like this check
yeah + d 4 yeah that's not going to end
well yeah some tricky lights but what
our own young place is the main move
actually before looks a bit strange what
is this it's a kind of a yeah a little
bit like the Sicilian wing game but yeah
you tried to give the beep horn against
the c-4 se porn and establish a central
dominance the main move here actually is
the move g6 but it was not played by two
pi love after g6 takes Bishop g7 black
tries to establish drawing banner him
establish a bind on default which very
often leads to very sharp play might for
example can try to go with this but his
whole center here is pretty shaky to
politic the porno ever possible now um
92 is the most common move nowadays but
Aronian goes for 95 he definitely has
something prepared here g six ND for
yeah white could have played Bishop g2 p
2 i'm sorry but did that after Bishop g7
would probably just lead to trades and
it's not clear that this isn't what's
best interest something like this for
example is just a bit lame yeah white
gets the porn back but he has this weird
King on everyone at his center it's not
really impressive but white wants to do
is he wants to build up something like
we see here he's got all pieces out
everything is centralized and the center
cannot easily be attacked get support
down of course here but yeah what has a
great central compensation the thing
that's not quite right is that the king
is here of course but sometimes you
could H for them so we'll see what
happens Queen d2 Queen a5h for Queen 85
is actually a move that is some pretty
heavily um criticized if you want by the
computer engines tend to play something
like rook c8 here and just trying to
develop
but this gives up their pawn and this is
not an easy the easiest thing to do
you've got this pond and you definitely
have the desire to win a game master
part of certainly has after that rotten
first part of the event so not quite
sure if you want to return the poem that
easily an interesting point is then if
what actually decides to take then here
that would be five is pretty strong very
nice idea after takes check tix black
castles and has excellent compensation
for the pawn with this kind of operation
black make sure that yeah the Queen side
and the play against the center gets
opened up and why it still needs a
little bit of PR sorting out to do with
the king on f1 and the rukon h1 seems
very okay for black this is what the
pile of played it looks like a normal
move but it seems to be risky after age
for there's the threat of age five he
played rook c8 and ignored this because
if h5 then their ideas like b3 here
interesting little tactic this this for
example we should be three was simply
preventing the whole thing yeah queen
bee five chick and h6 that's an
interesting idea to pull off wants to
yeah he prepares what he does next let's
say king age to now threatening to get
the rook to d1 and continue to play
white is not out for a quick mate yeah
or some kind of gap crazy h-file attack
or something like that he is mostly just
centralizing and trying to play for a
dominance in the middle of the board um
yeah what is black do here so part of
when g5 typically aggressive move of
them gets its trademark kind of chess
playing aggressively it is however very
tricky to play for
for black because um why does not have
to check i should should look at this
quickly check if takes then all of a
sudden Luke gets into the game was check
and this cannot be in whites interest
Luke t1 just played boronia calmly just
centralizing yeah and here at a pile of
decided to go g4 that's probably what he
had this has to do he didn't do that I'm
sorry he does he does the next move I'm
I wasn't seeing that right this is what
he probably should have done this is
what I wanted to say and he didn't do it
after G for whites night is attacked and
he will go to you five not to a passive
square and this is not a good idea and I
can take you that is interesting but
this is I'm sorry G 495 this is the far
more interesting move and also get from
my aggressive so this is why it should
be played black now probably has to take
and now rook c8 bishop CA de five yeah
Black is able to grab another partner
she probably should check and then g3 so
blankets two pawns up now but to play
this position is absolutely no fun I'm
not sure how bad it is I mean what seems
to have a very good game but how bad it
actually is it's hard to tell one thing
is clear if he castles which after a
while is given as the sorry be six sorry
b6 and Bishop f4 this is a key line in
this kind of line Black is in serious
trouble this is given as the best line
by the end of this is why I mentioned
castles um and after 97 King here 95
widens of course a lot better this is a
readily best line that the computer some
seem to find and if this is the
relatively best like is in a bad way
yeah it's tough to say what exactly went
wrong yet this is g5 approach Queen a
five probably everything is kind of
piling up a little bit on on black here
it's very difficult to play in the
practical game and probably objectively
also tricky this is played by to pawn
off and it might not be that terrible
but the way it turned out after King g1
and now we went rock d 8 maybe maybe
here there was a way to improve them um
yeah the engines like this capture a
little bit more even though this is not
easy to play note that the king is sort
of yeah it's kind of stuck there only of
eight and after night h4 white also has
an attack it's very difficult to give
them some advice like here how does that
continue we can have a look there takes
and now Luke c4 is a pretty strong move
attacking this black retreats this 97
now writes position is just immensely
active and black is uncoordinated he at
the end play droop d8 but now after the
double capture white is just an ass in
excellent shape he got his porn back and
do with equal material now he will just
attack note how badly placed at night is
only six it's totally yeah clogging up
the whole game he now captured on g5
Queen g5 and played Bishop 86 however
after the Queen retreated we saw that
there is a pin him push up to seven
Queen a form again this in 95 this is
the point f7 what is black supposed to
do if he plays f6 white is just able to
take yeah he decided to capture and
after Queen takes he resigned the game
to par loved it he does not have a
decent answer to the idea rook takes his
six with why crashing through only seven
like group c 8 for example and Brooke
chicks chicks chicks check and this is a
total disaster yeah this is a real
nightmare um event for photo/paul off he
has lost now I think it's just think
it's really for games if i'm not
mistaken and yeah it doesn't seem too
yeah it just doesn't get any bad i am he
just has a bad round after round after
round aronia now with his first win
which means that he's in contention to
win that event with this it seems modest
plus one score but it's enough to be a
close to the to the lead yeah gary was
leading with plus one sm was MBL and n
degree shock so let's continue with the
final the game to look at for around
seven and this is the the big one Carson
Nakamura yeah that's a really important
game Carlton is on fifty percent after
six round and he has to win something to
have a chance to win the event end the
tour and that camera is on +1 and if he
I mean it's difficult but if he wins
with black against Carson he would have
excellent chances to win the whole event
so actually I'm actually doing something
crazy i forgot to cover again i'm still
doing this now yeah i wanted to have to
do with that a lot MBL but let's do that
afterwards it doesn't matter this just
should have been the last game but i'm
kind of confused a little bit because of
my weird schedule today okay so it can't
knock I'm where I would win this he
would go two plus two and have fantastic
chances to win the overall thing you
know so super important game why is it
so chaplain okamura to win with black
well he never beat cars and so we'll see
what happens
in this game sloth defense with Bishop
g4 this Bishop geofoam is something that
Nakamura has not yet played against car
that he's not in classical chest he
mostly I mean there was a game with
Bishop f5 that count one very nicely
last year in the gushing of memorial so
this is my cameras um deviation from the
game page three Bishop h5 and this
capture here it doesn't look like like
much for white but it is some way of
getting a game as they as they often say
it's not a theoretically very demanding
position but you get to have yeah a
complex kind of game with many pieces on
the board this is what what is doing
posting the night up to 85 and then
grabbing the bishop am okay why why the
night from F and of the B night this is
the thing after h4 right is threatening
h5 winning a piece actually trapping
that bishop and this is very awkward for
black he has no no good move now if he
has to play something like h5 you might
as well resign the game so this is
correct why took mu sub G 296 and e4
Cardin wants to open up the position for
his two bishops certainly a logical
choice taken check and check why not
develop with check accelerate castling
Knight b6 this is a text upon and was
just ignored by Carlo it's an inner
interesting moment now in the game
because Nakamura now has a very um
principal choice he can play as he did
he castled but he did so rather quickly
he also could have taken on g4
this doesn't have very clear
consequences it is clear however that
white has some compensation for the porn
but it is not not a clear scenario at
all for example what could have happened
white could have played here just oops
that was a mostly just going for a
position like that where white has two
bishops against two nights and very
active bishops so this looks like some
compensation for example the move like
would be one putting pressure here
intending to push the sea porn or the a
porn it's definitely something that
white can play with white also can
consider to take on b7 this is a very
very sharp move of course after Luke
takes black has ideas here for example
Queen c7 attacking that bishop and
threatening made King g2 is a good move
now attacking here and this is the
position that check it's absolutely
difficult to to assess white is an
exchange up for porn but it's a total
mess now note that check this is not
good who cares no decent square very
complicated but this was possible for
Nakamura maybe he decided to Castle
however and the thing is now after d5 TX
takes the situation in the center is
clarified and why it just has the pure
bishop pair in an open position without
any kind of compensation of course it is
a symmetrical kind of porn distribution
it's two against two on the queenside
and three again three on the King side
which is of course helping the defending
side with the bishops however still he
basically said okay I'm going to play a
long game with you and I'm going to hold
this draw um yeah let's see what happens
Queen f6 got traded Bishop to f4 route
228 yeah all looks very normal Luke 21
yeah and now very interesting moment
here in this game like I'm well now
decided to kill this [ __ ] this night
that on c3 give up his real last
remaining Bishop and playing with two
nights against two bishops was that
necessary probably not he also could
have played differently something like
night c4 was interesting for example
however after be three white also seems
to a little bit be a little bit more
comfortable and I'd be true for example
might we'll take and centralize and it's
not clear that this helped at all the
other night looks a little bit misplaced
there something like this it's probably
not helping like he decided to take a
tough decision a very tough decision but
I think one idea that his certainly has
had was that here okay yes that counter
play him against the pawns but also the
pole structure then White House is not
ideal with a 25 lakh also has the open
file so maybe also was thinking that
there are chances that he wins one of
the pawns but that did not happen Carlin
was playing this in a very circumspect
way not dropping any pawns and just
playing in the most precise way so that
the rook ultimately had to go back now
Knight has to be brought back so that it
gets not captured or anything c5 book
did you note how wide how Carson managed
to push like a Morris pieces
back it was an active position for black
looked active but now he's back on the
final final three ranks so we get the
pure endgame two bishops against two
nights when we were talking in the
broadcast Grandmaster yeah molinsky very
um firmly stated that it is a clear case
where white wants to trade the rook to
make more office pure bishops advantage
against the night I was a bit surprised
about that but okay well I learned I
mean and you before but in that session
it was totally clear with the better end
game player um of course here white has
no chance at all to avoid the rib cage
but I would have thought that maybe
keeping more material would help the
bishops but this is really wrong here
the advantage of the bishop pan is just
very very substantial why with the
bishop Pam you can hear play on both
sides of the board white can make
progress on the Kings side trying to
sort of phone yeah find some entry there
for the king but he can also always
operate with the bishops um on areas of
the Queen side sometimes it is a simple
capture that is the key idea for example
if we look here after king of eight in a
situation if we just do this which is
not not super cliche maybe but i just
want to show the general idea sometimes
something simple like this capture can
be awkward for black because that night
is no squares covered and sometimes you
can even cover this square so the power
of the bishop pair is sometimes just to
the fact that it can capture the Knights
there is the other way round it is often
not possible i mean if the night takes
the bishop it just moves away but
sometimes the night can can just not
move away and it's just the nature of
this this type of
so how did Carlton continue he went f4
and was that he wasn't entirely happy
with afterwards I saw just a minute or
so of the press conference or their the
postgame interview and he stated that he
probably should have waited with that
decision and something like this and
Bishop 26 and was a good alternative yes
certainly this is what we had expected
during the broadcast but i'm not sure
that f4 is is bad at all and now an
absolute key moment it is move 41 Carson
now has more time on the clock they now
play with once a 1 minute 1 second no
not one minute one hour for the rest of
the game plus a 30 second increment
calendar has to decide how to set up his
his paw information and I expected
through g5 here and this is probably not
such a great idea I expected I was in
for something that I would have would
have considered let's say um my point
being that I would want to make this
possible and in some cases it's maybe
possible to get in something like f5 wyd
recaptures with the bishop let's say and
then h4 h5 h6 would be a passo on the
age from these were ideas that then i
had but council played the move after
long thought of f5 and this was exactly
what grandmaster yeah melinski also had
expected he said that this was the
standard way to play this kind of thing
it surprised me because the bone
structure now seems very static but
white has excellent chances now to make
progress um yeah with his pieces the
King can go can come up all the way to
g5 which makes the H pawn push possible
and in general he has opened up the
position more so
Bishop can come here and so on it is a
definitely difficult position for the
camera to hold but he did a very good
job for a long time Kingda 74 98 king g5
it's also clear that this is threatening
something but it looks still looks
dangerous we should have form a six that
is not a necessary movement was
criticized by carlson but it's a it's
hard to tell heavily I really have to
say I cannot cannot tell it didn't seem
very necessary to us during the
broadcast but we also couldn't really
have yeah figure out why it should be so
terrible h4 King back Bishop g3 a couple
of interesting possibilities of course
one interesting idea in this position
was this check on d6 something that is
interesting if or we can also yeah let's
look at this first 96 and now bishop c6
the question is is that a win nine f5
oops and here threatening night two is
six it seems questionable they are that
this should be waiting because if we
look at this we definitely see that this
night will be able to sacrifice itself
against the airport after which the H
pawn is the wrong partner it's a dark
squared corner and a light squared
Bishop one possibility Bishop g3
awaiting move Knight back check check
and here
97 that was Karen la camera set up to
try to hold this knight on c6 and night
on d7 this we've got some shuffling and
age 5 it seems that white has to go for
that H point push as I think Magnus also
stated later he felt that he needed to
dislodge that that night position that
it's not so stable anymore and check one
thing is clear check they repeated here
and they said this this was forced
however starting around here you can
definitely question what Nakamura is
doing we get one particular position
after which the the game is probably
lost but it's difficult to say when we
reach the point where you cannot save it
anymore I am not really sure that it was
lost in the first place but yeah it's
this is the moment where my time
constraint here today is showing I
really would have liked to know better
what went wrong there from na kabhi we
can't we can look at how I do it yeah so
that you see what I'm talking about he
gave that check now didn't want to stay
passer I mean he could have tried to go
back but this is an entirely passive
kind of kind of setup and this is in
fact zouk swine look at this this is why
I bishop is quite often better than
annoyed
and that's it complete zouk sorry so it
couldn't even go back this is why you
went for this and we we felt that black
now is it's critical it's definitely
critical but here interesting it's a
counter-attack if y no tix here then
Jack this is going to be check perfectly
okay for him this is why Bishop before
words played now this back and Bishop f4
yeah of course Carson does not want a
repetition this is the stronger move
Bishop f4 just keeping the whole
detention and um yeah this is the moment
I think after f6 it's losing and this is
what what nakamura played i think
carlton also said that f6 he felt after
that he should definitely win um but
it's tough to give black a clear advice
what you should do um if black tries to
sorry I take that bishop and we go to be
eight they make this Bishop d3 and this
is the idea now f6 he said winning four
wide it's tough to say it's really tough
to say of course it is yeah absolutely
no fun to play that with black but are
you losing I'm just making a couple of
most see how it might unfold it isn't
it's not a clear picture to me maybe if
you look longer with an engine you can
you can find out even though you have to
be very cautious there there are many
and games of that type when the engine
gives a white in this case it's wide a
huge advantage due to the bishop pair
and still there are some freaky
fortresses that will hold despite a pawn
down and against bishops it's not
totally clear to me if nakamura could
have saved but after f6 he is lost and
there's no way to save it now however
the reason why it is lost it's something
we'll see that it's really crazy okay
this should be fun night f2 back and
back and back and now of course carlton
goes for it Bishop takes be seven and
now what was the big big idea of all
that if black now takes on f5 let's
start with the eastern then king of six
will just win the game pretty easily
they denied is hanging it doesn't have a
great square yeah let's say here yeah
this is going to know that Nyjah for I'm
sorry but c6 probably this is probably
going to do it and other squares yeah
when you can what can you do here can
try this what channel I this isn't that
against it gets a piece and that doesn't
help at all now cameras idea was this
and it makes an awful lot of sense
attacks attacks attacks so what did
Carson do now Magnus just took on f6 and
this is the the move of them of the game
and probably the move of the tournament
yeah the great idea is that after night
x f4 and that's the only thing that puts
up some kind of resistance he's got King
e5 and his double attacking the Knights
the cool thing is that black doesn't
have anything great now that he can play
if he goes knight to e 2 let's start
with this one then Bishop a6 is a very
nice
illustration of why two nights that
protect each other are often a problem e
2 nite cannot move because of his
colleague or deform and this on f4 and
f-16 because he's essentially playing
with three extra pods black is
completely paralyzed so he had to go
night f2e to this is a much much tougher
choice yeah f6 played by cars the
engines claim that see success is
quicker better whatever but f6 this does
win as well but what he had to see is
the following point a5 a4 king of seven
chair jack king back and now why is it
is that positioned good for white in the
first place those nights as I said they
are tied to one another they absolutely
don't harmonize um at all and why it is
called a C and an 8th porn that both can
threaten to promote the black king alone
cannot stop both porns that's impossible
so in a way why does playing with extra
materialia in spite on paper he's a
piece down um the thing is however that
here there is only one one one way that
will win absolutely convincingly that
was was found by Carlton which is
remarkable the second great move of that
game I mean he played a couple of good
news but this is just excellent King to
reform what is the point the point is
that again black has a tough time to
move any of its nights and what white is
threatening is king III and Bishop c4
and then he will win one night for
nothing because of that miserable state
that those pieces I in yeah black has
absolutely no defense against this
double threat you can also start with
Bishop c4 and then go King you three he
tried this but now seasick
is going to be quick check check here
yeah something like this is just going
to promote check so check King e5 and
this was tried if he takes on d5 why
just takes and black is in no position
to to save this if he goes with this he
is of course far too late or just about
to later this is what he tried and now
oops double attack that's that's a way
to lose the game yeah Knight b6 and
there it goes and c7 King up and here
after Bishop takes a form a 4 Nakamura
resigned the game and this gets Carson
to a plus 1 score in the event and to a
plus 12 score without the loss against
knock and run so Carlton is on them yeah
he's on the scoreboard in a way yeah I
mean he had scored drawers but it's a
win finally after six drawers and that
means he has chances again to win that
event and maybe wind the overall tour
still even though he has not convinced
at all yet in the first two tournaments
and not so much in this event this was a
great game though grinding out that
window in a way typical Carlton game but
team hadn't really shown his endgame
magic yet and this in this tournament
now camera however has lost again to his
some rival and is falling back to a
50-percent scorned event which is a huge
setback um he he was leading the overall
standings of the tour but with that loss
will be very difficult to come back from
okay I had skipped one game I'm sorry
and I'm going to of course cover it
because it was very interesting it was
honored against mvl let's load it okay
no berlin by the way there mvl is a
night off flavored it was a berlin free
round yeah why not okay so we have an ID
wolf and MBL goes with this e 5 set up
and this is what v she is going for us
somewhat slow strategic line um focus on
centralizing and developing no quicker
texts nothing crazy um b5 dynamic move
attacking the center here on c4 white
cannot take twice as before is dropping
and here black is much more comfortable
with this to Center pawns against to
flank points that are far back this is
the far more prudent choice and now we
have a transformation after 95 widest
force and take and here we have a an
interesting situation its opposite
colored bishops which does not mean that
it's kind of drawn or not at all it
means that both sides have one color
complex that they can play on so black
often wants to play on some kind of dark
squares and white wants to use light
squares if possible for example
something like it's okay let's do a
black mafia that is what MBL did and uh
now castle which is fine something let's
say like a four yeah why it would
absolutely love for black to play before
so that they can use either light square
Bishop 1c4 may be attacking that porn
white wants to use them or get to some
kind of light squared dominance and the
same applies to black just with the dark
squares okay of course I line Castle 96
night go into that strong locating
square in front of the pawn
where'd stops the porn but also put some
pressure on a pawn a for that was part
of the agenda of course and now a good
move here by maxine Bishop g5 just try
to maybe take and take ok and now very
interesting concept he does not retreat
at all or play some other passive move
he goes to air for and the big idea is
that if white now tries to harass that
Bishop he has that counterblow f5 very
nice job here by black if white takes
amps there's a form and white will loose
material very funny situation that of
course also is not acceptable for wide
so Ireland just took on b5 still f5
that's a funny movie but very
aggressively played and if you play
passively in this kind of opening it's
rarely a good idea what now has to go 92
there's no big choice otherwise you
cannot keep the e4 pawn and term yeah
control of that 92 the next move
whatever good bye mdl is a mistake he
can play something normal here let's say
like 8x b5 and the position is equal in
a very dynamic sense let's say up white
kid take here and then black play
something like this for example try to
go for c4 very sharp position Black has
given a pond but upon that he very
likely will get back at some point white
can go night before at some stage but
black always has this c4 push so it's a
very yeah it's a very tough to play
position probably with equal chances but
it's a not like yeah her boring draw
anything so this is what he should have
done when he played Queen g5 very
aggressive looking move but hmm right
after this move we see why Alan is not
doing well in this event
it's only somehow Lexus technical
sharpness he plays now after some
thought the move route 81 like six
minutes and this is just a very very
passive move and and it's quite
mysterious what made him avoid the move
94 that was already suggested by llamo
in the broadcast and we could really
find we only looked at it very quickly
because we had some other action to
follow but yeah we couldn't make we
couldn't understand whether she was not
doing this it just by far better than
Luke 81 um one point is that after F
takes white has Queen age three and he
has said invasion idea here if I mean
white is better here it's just wide
being better legs pieces now look a
little bit awkward him for example 9 p-5
there is an IP 6 this is also sometimes
a possibility yeah here white is better
if he takes with the night only for
white will capture on a six and this
looks a little bit threatening to white
but there is no substantial threat
available the polonaise six is going to
be far more dangerous and don't forget
there are two of them two passes yeah 94
here was just better for Alan but he
went here and after this now black is in
good shape the look is all of a sudden
of an open file and it's a file that
black pudding controls so a very
mysterious choice why on earth felt that
he had to had to go for that e takes f5
Andrew k3 see how active black has
become 94 and now of course the great
reply see form yeah black does not want
to take or services just very weak in
comparison
this is just far more aggressive so if
white now takes the Queen black captures
and essentially to pisang not playable
white has to probably move the Queen and
here um the the engine still suggests
ways for white to to hold but I mean he
has to do that it's just like what he
did lose this right away but this is a
weird line now I can show anyway like
this threatening made g3 cheeks and
Queen back this is what the engines give
and they give white a decent position
quite funny what is not material down at
the moment it's equal and the thing is
that if those gets traded the night and
the deep on can be a factor for example
after this f6 is interesting attacking
that night and if the night's get traded
then the deep on is very very
threatening to black yeah note that
there are some problems with
coordination year mark here and the
possibility six there's also the threat
of Bishop c4 not that black is losing
but white has definite counter chances
this is what he had to do instead he
went to see two and this is again kind
of mysterious because Queen a5 is the
most obvious move there and why does not
have any reply to that if he tries to do
this to cover here there's root beer
three and this is just not good yeah
this is also a threat this and this
because after pawn takes Queen 83 whites
king is going to get mated yes stuff
like this is the the issue yeah very
mysterious game here bye bye Vichy after
Queen deggs f5 he's played queen bee to
Whoopi three and now decided to set the
Queen yet queen and night
only for the thing is this is just lost
but it had some interesting points this
thing happened and doesn't that look
somewhat threatening to black yeah
queeny's attacked Lucas detective 8 and
the bishop on Air Force also yeah looked
at but black has a direct winner check
yeah and now very brutal finish here man
rook takes f 2 yeah just killing the
whole game off if Y takes here now we
just recapture and black has a
completely winning position the B porn
is just far too much if he avoids the
instant capture than something like this
this is going to decide the day he has
no way to stop the pawns it's just
absolutely impossible yeah is there
something else that you can suggest this
move that was played by Vichy and we've
all got really scared for one moment
there when we saw the move Knight f7
check hmm that's kind of crazy and all
many pieces are hanging but nvm maxima
Sheila graph he had calculated all that
beforehand and he played that move just
calm Bishop d3 and it does with it
really does win if wife takes on d6 now
check this is happening and this is a
promotion note that the fall corn is
taking away the important square of the
bishop so roop 26 does not work and if
she checks we just take it
Bishop takes check it's going to be made
and if whiten takes here of course oops
I'm sorry check and again he cannot stop
the porn yeah what is left there for
white nothing fishy result so a tough
loss for a lot in that game after he had
lost to Greece shocked and around before
and it was a bad performance in this
game as well so he doesn't seem to be in
good shape at all losing the second game
in a row it also gets Maxine rush
Telegraph to a great score plus two
which is the lead in the event they have
the first player to have won two games
and now having the sole lead ahead of a
couple of players with plus one Giri
gree shocked Carlton and aronia so a
super super um yeah close close call
that event and we have seen some
interesting chess in this round no
balance but many other interesting
opening choices and also very
interesting end games especially that
Carlton Nakamura and game that you can
definitely explore a lot deeper than i
did now in this rather short video ok I
hope you enjoyed the coverage of round
seven I'll be back shortly with round
eight thanks for watching